just some breaking news to bring you
here
this is the arrival of Ukrainian
president zielinski he's arriving in
Saudi Arabia he's attending the Arab
League Summit which is taking place
there starting from today also notable
by his attendance is the Syrian
president Bashar al-assad who has been
reinvited back into that Arab League
after 12 years having been shunned from
it because of the Civil War taking place
in Syria but there we see president
zielinski has arrived in Saudi Arabia he
tweeted earlier today to say beginning
my first ever visits to the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia to enhance bilateral
relations and Ukraine's ties with the
Arab world political prisoners in Crimea
and temporarily occupied territories the
return of our people peaceful formula
energy cooperation KSA Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia plays a significant role and we
are ready to take our cooperation to a
new level so we didn't know that he was
on his way there until we got that tweet
and we have just seen him there arriving
being greeted by a delegation from the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia at the Arab
League Summit